the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show so
let's continue our sort of wrap-up of
the vacation yesterday I told my
vacation stories including a small car
accident and a near fainting episode and
anyway a whole bunch of other stuff from
my trip to Argentina to visit family now
as people might remember Pat before the
vacation you told us you'd be going on a
two-week road trip right you would be
hoping to see the eclipse of August 21st
from the line of totality you would be
going in a sort of you described it as a
campervan which I'm not sure is the
right term now we now we realize it may
not have been the right term so I I'm
happy to like walk us through the entire
thing or you can take it over the top I
mean I think it might be interesting to
first hear how did the driving part
start like where did your trip originate
and where was your first leg so to speak
so it started in Boston and the first
leg was over to Niagara Falls and you
know this plan changed a little bit from
when I announced it on the show sure but
I think it's important to point out
first and foremost that this van was not
up to the capacity that I thought it was
okay it was a 1997 chevrolet express van
so you were from from what it the
impression I got was you were thinking
it was more of like a glamorous RV no no
I thought it would just be a little bit
more reliable like I said 1997 chevrolet
express van with 220,000 miles on it the
unexhausted eek right so you know when
you're driving five six thousand miles
in total you have to wonder that some
problems can ensue sure and indeed they
did but that's a little bit later on
well so let's I guess jump to the first
point at which I don't think we need to
rehash every aspect of the trip that
kind of went as planned I think maybe we
should start is where did things start
to sort of take a turn just first a
little bit of foreshadowing right yeah
we're driving through the Midwest seeing
states I haven't been to before like
Ohio a little bit of Michigan where we
grab breakfast driving through Indiana
in Illinois with the
West yeah it's corn country we're
driving through a lot of corn now I
don't want to derail but out of
curiosity when someone like you who's
vegan stops in Michigan for breakfast
what do you get I have to do this like
there's this platter of potatoes with
vegetables on it I was completely off
the menu but I was actually impressed
with my own creativity I can order
something and of course I had Soylent
which is like a meal replace they're you
know thinking four or five bottles of
that every day
okay all right so anyway let's continue
with with where things started to go off
the rails okay so our first stop was
going to be Badlands National Park in
South Dakota and about 20 or 30 miles
away from there right before approaching
we stopped to get gas in vivianne South
Dakota and if you've never heard of that
town before I don't blame you because
it's very very small and you know we
fill the tank
and the car won't start okay that was
like the first big issue now was the was
the gas tank basically empty at this
point if we put 50 bucks in it so yeah I
mean it was it was pretty full at that
point what I realized was my whole life
when I filled gas I would choose the
option of 87 unleaded which is always
furthest left sure well at this
particular gas station there was 87
unleaded and 87 unleaded with 10%
ethanol okay and I made the mistake of
putting 10% ethanol in the gas tank okay
right so the car won't start we're
realizing this is an old van it lived
most of its life in the Northeast where
there's really not that much ethanol gas
you know I probably screwed up big here
the whole fuel systems probably busted
we tried starting the car a few times so
maybe it's in the engine and it's gonna
be this big fix after a few hours we
call triple-a the triple-a a driver
comes over and he just says yeah ethanol
gas should be fine just just open up the
the fuel tank let it breathe a little
bit right and we start the car and we're
on our way
interest and we get to Badlands National
Park okay to enjoy it for the following
day which is really nice and I'd like to
be able to go through the story and just
talk about the wonders of America and
this beautiful diversity of land that we
have and the great geographical sites we
were able to see but the story derails a
little bit further after the badlands so
you get to badlands and is that a place
where there are there many animals to
see or is it most
landscape just-just landscapes of like
barren rocks and stuff maybe I'll put
some pictures up and post it it is it is
really nice a really nice place but the
problem was we still have ethanol in the
gas tank
which you know despite what this guy
working for triple-a said is kind of a
problem yeah because we're starting and
stopping the car so frequently to make
all these stops along the Badlands route
we try starting the car when it's you
know 12:00 1:00 in the afternoon and the
heat combined with the altitude combined
with the ethanol gas made it so that we
couldn't start the car now let me ask
one question here because I know someone
who once had a diesel rental car and put
gas in it and regular unleaded regular
unleaded gas and they actually were able
to start the car and then they just kept
at every opportunity adding diesel like
the percentage of fuel in the tank as
much diesel as possible yes i diluted a
little bit yeah were you guys then
getting regular 887 unleaded as you
could we that was the plan but the thing
was we hadn't driven that far from the
last time we filled up with purely
ethanol gas right it's not like there's
gas stations in the Badlands it's just
too remote of an area yep so we had to
get towed out of there and we got towed
to the nearest city which is Rapid City
South Dakota Wow which we ended up
spending about five days there okay so
so we ended up going to this mechanic
who charges
I guess my friend that I $800 to fix the
whole thing Wow and we make it clear to
them that we think it's because of the
ethanol in the tank and the guy puts at
the same gas that he took out back in
the tank after he fixes it ablaze the
whole fuel system and puts the exact
same gas back in the tank and then does
it start it starts yeah I mean I like
the thing barely has power I mean you
can sell it it's hard to get up hills I
mean you know it's very high up in
elevation over in South Dakota so we
were really struggling we we just wanted
to kind of stay in the area I think the
weekend had approached so I knew that
the mechanic was gonna be back till
Monday we wanted to take it to firestone
we wanted to bring it back to the
mechanic and just kind of just stay for
the weekend in South Dakota so we can
get it all fixed and so we ended up
staying like four or five days in Rapid
City which isn't horrible because
there's a lot of stuff out there you
know there's Mount Rushmore
there's crazyhorse we actually did this
date or thing where we went to all these
sites and it ended with a chuck wagon
Wow have you heard of a chuck wagon no
you know it's basically this this this
meal and show it's like a variety show
that you witness the thing started with
a prayer and edit with this ended with
this like big salute to America where
everyone got on their feet and they
brought down the American flag it really
was like the heart of America was it
mostly right-wingers at that event you
know there was just all old white people
yeah not not too different from what
you'd expect but so now when you say the
weekend this is the weekend right before
the the infamous now infamous Eclipse
right what ended up happening on Monday
the 21st well I wanted to rented a car
to rent the car because the low line of
totality didn't go through South Dakota
but it did go to places that were a
hundred two hundred miles away from
there
including Alliance Nebraska and Casper
Wyoming okay so my intention was hey
we'll just rent a car for a day that's
gonna be like hundred bucks you know
we'll be able to see the clips from the
line of totality sure problem was all
the rental agencies either had all of
their cars out being loaned because
although the people want to see the
Eclipse or they just price gouged them
to like 400 bucks so it wasn't even
gonna be worth it for a single day to
see the Eclipse okay so my friends and I
have this idea to either recruit people
that we could meet in Rapid City to
bring us down there cuz maybe they would
want to go to and we can throw them some
money for gas that's into work even
though we tried spending a couple days
out at bars and trying to meet people
and be social so we post a craigslist
asking if headhunted is intending on
going to the solar eclipse right if
they're willing to bring us there that
we can we can give them gas money and a
little bit extra so it would be worth it
to him and one guy responds to our
Craigslist ad and what does he say he
says I'm already bringing some guy down
there it's just this older gentleman and
thinking his 70s he's from California
and he was heading towards the line of
fatalities so we're like alright great
we get some free Eclipse glasses from
the library in Rapid City South Dakota
nice at you know 9:00 in the morning at
that point we have a few hours to spare
because the Eclipse out in Mountain time
was around 12:00 to 1:00 the clock and
you know we get in this guy's car that
we just met off of Craigslist and this
old man comes out not really with a
sense of urgency that we really have to
get there in time yeah he's just being
kind of
today's little cool about doesn't seem
like someone who's getting to something
at a definite time of day no no because
you know you think this guy we could
tell went to bed early the day before
just because of text messages that were
exchanged you know he got in line at the
library to get solar eclipse glasses way
too late where they are already run out
so at this point we get that there's not
much of a sense of urgency we start
driving to the middle of nowhere through
South Dakota into Nebraska a little bit
- yeah and it turns out that the guy
didn't really want to go to the solar
eclipse he wanted to go to Wounded Knee
okay which is like an Indian Reservation
it turns out this guy named dick iDEN
was writing a memoir about his life and
he wanted to revisit some of the places
he had been to so I guess he worked as a
lawyer for Native Americans in the 70s
at standing at a Wounded Knee yeah and
he wanted to go to all these places I
guess I looked into this guy later I
guess he he ran for Congress for Darryl
ices seat and actually was the second
runner-up in that contest in 2012 wow
that was pretty remarkable that I mean
this guy and we didn't actually get to
the line for the solar eclipse but the
entire time as we're driving we have the
Eclipse goggles on and were able to see
like a good partial eclipse it's the
point where there was maybe like a
sliver of Sun left so that be clear Pat
I don't want to interrupt here but dick
iDEN was not the driver he was the
passenger yeah he was the passenger who
was kind of dictating where the car was
going yes he kind of had dibs on this
whole operation yeah you went to
Craigslist first in fact so long story
short though you didn't actually get a
ride to the line of totality because
that's not where this duo was going no
he went to Wounded Knee and if we had
known about this all along I mean the
adventure was nice but we probably would
not have done that we probably just
stayed in Rapid City and partial clips
from there so when we get back I mean
like this driver wants money from us
then we're like dude you didn't take us
the Eclipse we went to this random
Indian Reservation and we did this trip
that this this old other this other guy
wanted to do not to be clear do we still
call them Indian reservations or are
they native African out there they
they've embraced the term Melkonyan
Verena that's right that's what I've
seen there and actually this is the the
first time I've really had long in-depth
conversations with Native Americans and
American Indians interested that was a
good experience as well so I mean you
know the guy wants some money for
bringing us down there and we're like
dude you didn't take us to the Eclipse I
mean here's 20 bucks but we're not gonna
give you like exactly what you asked for
yeah and then we just kind of left and
that was our solar eclipse experience
this was like halfway through the
vacation right so then so now we're
basically at the end of Monday into
Tuesday which is starting to be the end
of the second week of the vacation how
does the trip wrap up well we're still
having car troubles right I mean at this
point I'm just worried about getting
home I'm it's my friend's van so he's
looking into all the different places he
can go to get a bit fix bringing it back
to the mechanic you know because he
seems like he feels like he's been
ripped off at this point I paid 800
bucks and really didn't get the problem
fixed so maybe he can take it back to
the guy because it's Tuesday and the
solar eclipse is over now I'm able to
rent a car so that's exactly what I do I
rent a car I say hey you know you can
figure out the van issues while I go
because this time is very valuable to me
you know I offered for him to come too
but it just really didn't make sense
because he had to work on the mechanics
of the vehicle in that situation so for
three days I I rented a car and I went
out to Yellowstone National Park which
was originally our destination yeah very
happy to go there probably you know the
most beautiful place in the whole
country if not the whole world I mean
wow the diversity of landscapes and the
geysers and and you know though the
waterfalls and the scenery it's just
amazing out there so it was enjoyable
but also the campgrounds were filled up
so I really didn't have a place to go
for the few days that I was there yeah
you know there wasn't a lot of planning
involved I was driving through the
middle of Wyoming at the middle of in
the middle of the night where it's
really not the place you want to be down
like dirt roads I mean all these things
it was just it was just terrifying you
scroll through the radio stations and
you get nothing I mean you'll go through
a whole cycle of radio stations if you
get something it's like you know
religious talk radio or country music I
went through this town of 10:00 sleep
Wyoming with population 200 I mean just
the entire thing was terrifying him I'm
by myself for all of this - so you make
it to Yellowstone and you see it in all
of its of its majestic glory DC animal
life
oh yes yes so that was one of my goals
for this trip I wanted to see a bison
because I had never seen a bison before
and there's you know the Yellowstone is
a big place I think it's 300 square
miles and there's this long entrance no
matter from which side you came from I
came from
east entrance and I was like all right
yes I'm driving through I this place
looks kind of cool but I don't know if
it's anything too unique and then I
approach Yellowstone Lake on this curve
and I'm driving maybe you know 40 50
miles an hour around this curve and I
see a bison just walking down the road
on the other side and my jaw just
dropped you know I came to a stop safely
it wasn't like I was in danger of
hitting him but I was just so inspired
by this massive animal just casually
walking down the street well I got a
couple pictures of them but um he walked
maybe two feet next to me on the side of
the car it was the most amazing thing
I've ever seen in my entire life and
that was the beginning right Yellowstone
animal didn't say a word you didn't say
a word for a slobbered a little bit okay
bobert a little bit yeah but if you call
this the climax of the trip I would say
so I mean no that was the point I wanted
to get to you know I we we plan to go
into Yellowstone and it's too bad my
buddy couldn't come along with me but
you know I was able to get there right a
few days in Yellowstone saw all the
sights I wanted to see very happy great
pictures all that stuff then I heart I
started making this quest back so you
know I get back to Boston on Monday but
in Thursday I'm driving through Montana
you know trying to get back to South
Dakota so we can pick up the car and all
this stuff I get back to South Dakota
you assume the van will be ready to go I
assume the van will be ready to go I
mean you know we've had three or four
days to get this thing fixed right all
these different appointments I'm about
20 miles out of South Dakota and I call
my friend and say alright so you know
the band's running we can start a
journey back you know at this point it's
Friday and he goes yeah it won't start
I won't start so at this point I'm like
alright do I need to get a plane ticket
back I mean same-day plane tickets out
of Rapid City that's gonna be like five
six hundred dollars what am I gonna do
like I gotta get back somehow and we had
the car towed again or at least we were
planning to but when the Triple A driver
shows up we were just able to try a
different key and that worked it started
the car miraculously we don't even know
why because we couldn't even hear like
the fuel pump buzzing when we put our
year against the the gas tank huh it
just it was a miracle and we didn't
expect it to start again we thought that
would be the one time that it started
and we just have this this one time to
get up and go and get as far home as we
can even if it's like Chicago we can get
relatively easy from there but we're
just thinking like what if it doesn't
start again we're in the middle of
nowhere
we just got to go home you know we this
is like a 30 hour drive plus yeah we're
just gonna we're just gonna get back
we're just gonna drive and keep going
and we were gonna switch off every few
hours try to get sleep when we can but
we're just gonna do this in one shot now
you know you think when you when you
pump gas you're supposed to turn the car
off yeah just what everyone does I guess
but I guess it's really not that bad if
you just leave the car on I've heard the
same thing you know you can't fill it up
all the way because then the gas will
start splattering everywhere but yeah
that's what we did we just went from
South Dakota
to New Jersey where my friend lives in
one shop in LA a day and a half when I
did the I did the hours of like midnight
1:00 a.m. 2:00 a.m. he did the tougher
hours and I think 3 4 5 6 a.m. it was it
was a miraculous journey and we were
able to get back to New Jersey
incredible yeah and then I figure out in
New Jersey that my friend has like some
other commitment to make and I have to
get a bus back or a train back from New
York City and you know that's where that
ended so I was pretty exhausted
yesterday for you know it wasn't even
really even able to be on air because I
was just too sleep-deprived and to
psychologically burdened by this whole
experience you were in panic mode
Oh oh it was panic Pat absolutely I mean
I spent the entire week or at least a
few days just just trying to get home
and I finally get here and I still feel
like I'm not home you know it was it was
quite the journey I mean like I have the
pictures to show for it that it was a
great experience and no one does that
some some cool pictures and all these
these great sites and everything but it
was an experience incredible we'll
listen I think there's been no shortage
of character bill it didn't go exactly
as planned but I think this will be an
experience you will not forget and for
better or worse I think we can say and
all right so there's Pat's vacation
we're out of time but tomorrow we will
get back to agent
bonus show the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]